so i'm indeed i work on open pilot
and i'm going to talk about uh
mostly testing but uh as i've said
there's going to be a couple of fun
announcements at the end
so
we're going to talk about
quality
and how we don't break stuff
because uh
oppai is getting to be a big project
and
we support two hardware platforms now
with two different operating systems one
based on android and one based on ubuntu
we do roughly monthly releases that are
fairly large
this one in particular was a recent one
that's pretty large
um
this one
so these are a couple of releases that
we did recently um
they're pretty big um we have a small
team
we support 132 cars as of today
um
various brands
and we have over 200 plus contributors
in the last well since last january
um
since we went so we changed development
style and we developed publicly now
so how do we not break stuff
this is a commit from 2016.
and we had a dream back then
one day we'll have ci
and then here we are july 2021
um so these are
some randomly sampled desks at the
office
and you'll notice
there are no common devices on these
desks
they're just computers they're built to
work stations
and
this is largely our development workflow
now
we sit at desks not on cars anymore
and
the answer to how we don't break stuff
is
we have automated regression testing and
human testing
we do hardware in the loop tests we do
offline checks
for anomaly detection and we do online
checks
on the device
so the testing goals for open pilot are
enforcing quality
reducing the time spent in cars um
as we showed with that picture on the
desks
and efficiently scaling a small team
because the open pilot team is about
three full-time people with a research
team that is now four full-time people
and we have a very concrete goal of a
thousand hours mean time between failure
for 1.0
so some of the automated checks we do um
these are the public ones at least
we have a github actions test suite
that runs unit tests
this test process replay that's fairly
important and we do these car unit tests
that are
also pretty important
then we have um a jenkins server that
runs our hardware in the loop tests
where we have comma threes and comma
twos
um
going on road running real segments um
doing replays
and
enforcing things like are the timings as
good as we want
is the cpu usage exactly as we expect it
to be
things like that
and then uh you guys have probably seen
the online checks if you use open pilot
um sometimes you'll get a fan mail
function sometimes you've got a gps
malfunction
it'll say contact support and then what
people do
they go to discord but
when the alert works you should contact
support
we try really hard to make these alerts
and be very aggressive about it but also
um prevent the stuff from going out in
the field
but yeah we do
some pretty extensive checking across
all the different services in open pilot
we make sure that all the services are
live they're healthy and their sources
for data are also healthy so if um
like one of the sensors is bad for
example this will propagate all the way
through through location d through the
planner and controls will say okay we
can't engage now or we have to disengage
now
and then this is uh one of our
more important tests that run some
github actions
it's called process replay
and we can deterministically
replay
segments through routes or through uh
processes and we can take
the same set of inputs and assure that
we get the same set of outputs and if we
don't we generate these nice diffs as
you can see here
um
so this is a diff for one of uh
for actually the new model that we just
uh
tried to ship in 087 but
we had to revert
which will hopefully ship soon but this
is the diff that it generated um we
switched to
um
some different lead packets and stuff so
you'll notice the difference here it
tells you exactly what changed and we
can know
given two different commits um
what will the outputs of this particular
open pilot service be
did they change in the ways that we
expected
or did they not change so a lot of times
we'll do a refactor where we expect that
nothing changes
and this is pretty important because we
can do things like
we can review pr's really quickly you
read the diff you make sure the diff is
reasonable
you do your diligence there but if the
green check mark is there on github
actions you can be reasonably certain
that this did not change any behavior of
the tested open pilot processes and this
runs on all the driving processes
so there's six critical driving
processes and this covers all of them
and some other
ones then we do um some car unit tests
and these car tests are super important
for scaling to these 132 cars
that
we haven't really touched so we have six
cars in the office right now
we've probably touched somewhere in the
neighborhood of a few dozen cars over
the lifetime of the company
um but all the other ones come through
pull requests pull requests that are
fairly small but uh it's still important
to make sure that these cars work
because we sell devices we want to
ensure quality and
there's really no reason not to we
invested
quite a bit of time in making these very
reliable unit tests
and now we can be reasonably certain
that every car that openpile has a test
route for
functions to some degree we can't
we don't necessarily check driving
behavior but we check system behavior
will this car throw a can or will the
frequency checks work on this car
will panda safety agree with open pilot
because if this isn't true um
as you heard in robust stock the panel
will just block the messages
so this asserts some very basic behavior
and allows us to effortlessly scale to
uh the next milestone in cars which
maybe is 250 1000 cars
and then this is a part of our suite of
offline anomaly detection so we have a
pipeline stage called find interesting
that runs on all the incoming data
and this runs on those queue logs that
um anybody who runs open pilot uploads
and these are some tiny logs that we get
a lot of information about all the
devices in the field
um
we can
so this is
this is like a real screenshot from our
dashboards that we have up in the middle
of the office um
so you can see right now some of the top
errors are with um
some there's some panda stuff there's
some camera d stuff on the comma two
there's some a little bit of poor model
timings on release
and we have this cool iteration loop we
do with find interesting where
we aggressively
log everything that we
want that we expect to happen with
openpilot
and then we look at it and find
interesting and we look at the data that
comes in and if this isn't happening
it's gonna show up and find interesting
it's gonna be one of these top things
oops
clickers are hard
oh yeah there we go
so you see that these panda errors are
dominating right now
a year ago it used to be overheats can
errors all these other things
but every release we look at the top few
things and we fix them and then you just
end up with a way more reliable system
when you're tracking the things that you
care about because if we don't track
these things they're going to regress
and this is our testing closet you may
have heard about it it's a little bit of
a strange name
but
the name comes from the closet it was
originally housed in
in the original comma house
and you can see
you can see some comma threes here
running different branches
um you can see some comma twos
um these comma twos are running an eos
update that was supposed to ship in a
previous release but that didn't make
the cut because of some things we found
find interesting that i'll show you in
the next slide um but this is how we
verify um something like the long tail
reliability in that
there's no reason open pilot shouldn't
just run if we if we connect it to a
what we call a jungle and this allows us
to essentially emulate the behavior of
uh being in a car and driving around
there's no reason it shouldn't run um
for days and weeks and months and
these comets whose here have been
running for a little over four weeks
so far
this was with obviously a version of
open pilot from about a month ago but
we update these devices fairly often and
we
were able to be reasonably confident
about
the reliability and behavior of these
devices and it'll compile it
because of the data we get back from the
testing closet
here's some plots from the testing
closet these are diffs of consecutive
messages from different open pilot
servers so we have calibration d's
message we have one from d modern model
d
um we have one from the planner and we
have one from
the monitoring model d so these are four
different open pilot processes that
we're looking at messages from
and we can see that the timings are
they're they're pretty good for the
planner um
they're a little bit worse for uh
the modern model d and then you'll
see the modern d and d monitoring model
d um follow because they're driven by
each other but uh
we can
assert some timings
as we can see in the next slide
so this is the
timings of board d so bordea is a
process that talks to the panda um in
your car so that's
um you have
if you remember from robestock you have
uh your comma device the combat 2 or 3
now and you have the panda which is
built into the device but nevertheless
it's a it's a distinct device um
and we talked to it over usb on both
devices right now
and this timing is super important
because it drives the rest of the stack
the camera and the panda drive the stack
essentially
and that's why camera d and board d are
super important for um
latency and real-time performance so
if more g is performing poorly the rest
of the processes that
rely on board dr gonna perform poorly so
just controls the which is what actually
talks to your car
so we worked really hard to get these
timings
to the point where it doesn't miss a
cycle anymore
um
and then this is why we didn't ship that
neos update a couple releases ago
there's still a pr open for neos 18.
about a year ago we wrote this daemon
that fixes um
these random canters where you would get
lags on comma twos
randomly where it would seem that board
d just wouldn't get would run
for
uh dozens of milliseconds and then
you get these lags
because of our strict online checks
so
you can see out in the long tail here
you have it lagging for almost 100
milliseconds
and it does this
um quite a few times if we go back to
the previous slide
it never does this so
this is some of the behavior we certain
testing closet
um
it was pretty important for assuring
that we don't ship progressions um and
then we're hitting the targets that we
aim to
and this is pretty cool so we
all of the github action tests that we
run on our repo
you can run on your repo too we put the
effort in to the point where you can
click the fork button and then you click
allow actions and you will have
a large portion of our of our testing
infrastructure running on your fork if
you're there's many popular fork
maintainers out there um who have
sometimes hundreds of users um and you
have all this testing infrastructure
that we've built up you can if you do uh
if you support cars that we're never
going to support for example the mosses
that have the steering lockout
we don't intend to support these cars or
at least claim
that they're an open pilot experience
but you can
you can reach
as much as you can like you can support
the car to almost the flow of stat that
we can um by using the test
infrastructure that we have and it's
really you click this one button you go
into the settings for your forked repo
and you enable github actions
now we're going to talk about panda
testing
so we have two goals for panda
it should enforce the functional safety
that we've defined for openpilot
and it should enforce the hardware
functionality um so you know you tell
the panda to send this can message it's
just on the can message
so here's an overview of the testing
infrastructure for panda we do unit
tests again in github actions we do
replay tests where we take a segment and
it's very similar to process replay
where
we assert that the behavior hasn't
changed
from commit to commit
and then we do some static analysis
robot talked a little bit about mizra i
think in his q a and iso 262 um so our
unit test and our stack analysis um
go a long way to cover the uh code rigor
that we have that we uphold in panda um
that isn't necessarily um a goal of open
pilot
and then we have hardware and loop tests
that run on the whole zoo so they run on
every panel that we've ever made from
white grey black uno dos
so
our safety unit tests are pretty cool
because you can write
all the functional safes you need for a
brand new carport and you can write a
test for it and on average the test is
about 165 lines um which is something
you can reasonably do in an afternoon or
uh or a weekend and you can develop
functional safety for your brand new
carport um
and verify the functionality without
ever going in a car or even doing a
replay
so i think this is incredibly cool
and we oh we have tesco all these cars
all these safety modes that ship and
open pilot release
and this runs for every hardware
combination of every car we support so
we support 132 cars we support quite a
few pandas that's that's a lot of
combinations
and then we do hardware in the loop
tests um we assert things like can
latency can loopback
this essentially maintains that
if i send out a message do i get it back
um and we can do this with multiple
pandas we use um something i'll talk
about a little bit later the panda
jungle
we also do some checks the car harness
that we're correctly detecting ignition
all this other kind of stuff
and then i want to talk a little bit
about production building devices um
because this is also pretty cool
george talked a little bit about screen
calibration
this is some of the stuff we've just
gotten to do because we've gotten really
good at testing these devices that we
can do the fun stuff
uh
we'll go back
so after your comma device is built what
happens
so we flash it with neo s or agnos
you have a comma two or three
we do some initial checks to filter out
defective units
and then we have this provisioning stage
which runs quite a few tests
and asserts all the hardware
functionality
that we design
our combat devices for
and then we have a 24-hour stress test
um that george talked a little bit about
in his presentation
um
and this is
this is how we're working towards
building these really incredible devices
that i think
you guys will get hopefully uh after the
first shipment on thursday
so this is our provisioning stage this
is what happens after flashing and we do
that
initial check and make sure there's
nothing obviously wrong like
does it have all the sensors or is it
missing the modem
after it passes those basic checks it
goes on to final provisioning and these
are some very early comma threes
and we started writing these tests
fairly early on
we wrote these tests a couple months ago
and we've really iterated on them in the
last couple of weeks but
um these are some old revisions of the
comma three and they um
you can see some of them failed some of
them are still running the test and some
of them pass but it's cut off um
and we verify things like sensors
is wi-fi working is lte working
are all the things the right firmware
versions that we expect
is the camera in focus this is becoming
more important with the comma 3 because
we focus the cameras ourselves we have a
lot of control over the process but this
means there's a lot more that can go
wrong so
testing becomes a little bit more
important in some aspects comma 3.
then we also do some testing with the
panda the internal panda to the uno and
dos and your comma twos and threes
um
and we can
basically be confident about all the
hardware that we're shipping out um
just based off this quick test this test
runs um in a couple minutes and it
asserts all the instantaneous
functionality we can check
we do some
there's a
in the daughter board that george talked
about in his uh presentation that goes
on top of that uh
that modem on the comma three
there's a there's a beeper
and
that fires when you uh device powers off
essentially
while it's still engaged
and uh there's we do tests like that we
you hear these all throughout the office
we go through a lot to test these
devices we have some really cool tests
with that
and then uh it also does a server
registration
then we do the stress test um
so this one's pretty cool because we
have all sorts of different failures we
caught on the stress test um we check
for temperature this one used to be
super um super important to combat two
because the device would fail a lot
we check for gps accuracy now
we do
a lot of camera checks like are we
dropping frames
uh are we getting any errors from the
camera at all this indicates some kind
of assembly defect
where a screw isn't screwed in all the
way stuff like this
and we have these very strict checks
and it runs for a continuous 24 hours
no like if it happens two times then
we'll let it pass these are super strict
at it turns red when it fails it's uh
it's alarming we pull it off the rig and
it goes back in the production process
and then this is a pretty cool
chart so
we shipped the comma twos with uh some
some testing that we could think of
beforehand but there was a lot of
unexpected failures with them and a lot
of the tests were written after things
happened in the field and then we found
out that this is something we really
need to test for this is something that
varies quite a bit from device to device
as we still establish these production
processes
so
this um
this kind of shows how we improve these
devices over time and
how
every device that has been shipped also
benefits from the improvements from
the device that we make in the future
so
we said we used to set aside all the
comment twos that failed um
this is our first serious time doing
production so we we do the tests and
failed either final provisioning or the
stress test we put it to the side and it
goes in a bin and we just have walls and
walls of um
particular failures
ranging from very minor things like
we need to
fix up some solder joints or something
to the cpu is too hot
this is
some kind of
device failure or we need to do
something more major
to fix this
so cpu too hot
around i think uh september october of
last year was by far the
um
biggest uh and most common failure for
the comma twos
so we
reduce cpu usage in open pilot and then
we
down clock the cpu fairly significantly
to get these devices
to pass the stress test and
we went a little bit above and beyond
here
we
did a more extreme down clock
and
the orange
part of the histogram here is
the
devices that were too hot and failed the
stress test
after the down clock and the blue ones
are the device all the devices we ship
before that with the current uh clock
frequency
so the device that were too hot actually
ended up being
running even cooler than devices we
shipped out before that passed the test
and then every device in that blue
category also benefited from this
because we shipped an ota update
to the kernel
and all the devices got cooler in the
fields
and then this is pretty cool here's a
gif of the screen calibration
so we've thought about comma 3 testing
for a long time and how we're going to
test them in production
and we got to do some fun stuff
before we shipped out the first units
so i think it's this kind of shows how
far we've come
from the comma two
a couple years ago to where we are at
with the three right now
where we can we can do things like this
and you look at them and the stress test
is uh we go back stress test
the stress test is pretty big it's it's
this is a small part of it and you can
see all these devices on the stress test
and their screens look exactly the same
this is uh
we put a
comma two next to the comma threes
yesterday
um
and
the difference is incredible these
devices are really beautiful and we have
time to do things like this now um in
the capacity so
i think
i think you guys will be really happy
with these devices
and then now we're going to take a trip
to the kamazoo well for the premier san
diego zoo which is the kamazoo
and we're gonna talk about the panda
jungle so the piano jungle is what most
of us who have a device on our desk use
to uh do replays and to debug and
develop open pilot
um so pano jungle essentially has a
panda on it and it has six obdc ports so
you can plug in six comma two six comma
three six pandas whatever you want
and this is how we do our hardware loop
testing for pandas this is how we
develop open pilot on desks
you can essentially emulate being in a
car on your desk
and it's an incredible debugging tool
and then now it has a working ignition
button we ship nine of these devices and
the last well since we started selling
them we shipped nine of them
and uh we just got the ignition button
working
but we have an announcement it's gonna
be 199 now
all right
so hopefully we'll get another nine
people to buy them
and we have the next gen panda
red panda
[Applause]
so the red panda is based on an stm32h7
the previous generation of panda was
best was based on the stm32f4
we've been doing work um in the last
three months to develop this device and
bring it up
it's the future of the panda platform
it supports can fd has a forex faster
cpu
and it's red
so it's the
same black pan to form factor
in a red case without gps
you'll be able to connect this to your
comma 3
directly to that usbc port
and then you can buy one today 299
and
it ships in two to eight weeks
and uh we're optimistic live support and
open pilot um
in the next release 08.
[Applause]
questions
okay so there's a couple things there um
we're not quite at the scale of selling
hundreds of thousands
yeah
maybe
but uh
as far as reworking the devices
it is it costs a lot of
time but
it's really clear now that this time is
really worth spending uh it made every
comma two we ever shipped out
much more reliable uh and a much better
product um so i think right now the the
time we invested in and we we do this uh
kind of in stages so we do the
production process we build devices we
set them aside and then it's kind of
like to find interesting loop we look at
the top failures we fix them um or we
evaluate what can we do about these can
we improve processes can we improve uh
the software at all like where can we do
better um
and it turned out for the comma two we
fixed all the common failures and this
made all the devices that much better
you buy a comma two today um and it's
incredibly well tested
um
so yeah it is worth spending the time
but we do it in stages we don't just you
know immediately rework them
was there another component to your
question i think i covered everything
um
how can we catch them earlier
yeah so um
we we try to
push test downstream as much as possible
until the earliest stages and we've
gotten really good at this with the
combat threes already actually
we catch almost all the failures in
final provisioning which takes a couple
minutes you build the device um you
flash it
um there's a couple stages of flashing
actually so we flash just the boards
themselves then we build it into a
device then we put agnes on it um
and then we do some final provisioning
and
um
we've gotten really good at this
actually so we we do
we add these tests when necessary and uh
yeah the the final provisioning tests
are really quick
where we catch these super early in the
production process actually
do you even know that one up here
actually
oh yes thanks um since again nice
presentation nice work on
testing one question i have for you guys
uh maybe like um
for improvement uh you guys planning on
doing like some thermal cycling of the
devices some thermal what cycling like
uh
freezing them basically like to minus 10
at minus 20 and then hitting the knob
pretty quickly because that's what
really happens
in practice and my device actually had a
problem coma too
after after whistle trip when it stayed
outside and cool down to -10
screen just stopped working
okay um
so i think your question about thermals
i i couldn't quite understand that yeah
like thermal testing like they guys plan
on doing like thermal cycling
yeah so i think we we plan
to we cover all the hardware right now
um pretty thoroughly but there's a lot
of room um there's a lot of depth to go
into um in the testing our testing will
get much better we'll go through the
same process we did with the combat 2.
the comma 3 testing is where the combat
2 testing um
it kind of picked up from there we
didn't start over so i think the combat
3 testing will be really i think it's
quite incredible right now i think it's
going to get you saw the screen
calibration yeah this is but what i'm
saying is that coma is not not really
it's a little bit different from
consumer electronics because uh it's a
great and condition can
can go from minus
10 for example celsius to i don't know
80 degrees pretty quickly yeah so that's
not your playstation like use case
scenario usually
yeah
yeah um
just something for improve thanks
so with the red panda and the new car
config or in the comma car configurator
when you're trying to see if your car is
supported if you need a red pan to
support your car is that going to show
up in in the configurator
yeah so this is something we we could
easily do no cars require the red panda
right now but i think some cars are
starting to ship like some genesis cars
or starting to ship with canfd want to
when the first can if the carport comes
in we'll we'll handle this all nicely
gotcha and can you maybe speak to the
what's on can fd and why it's important
to have that support in the red panda
yeah so it's just an upcoming uh
standard it's it's kind of the next step
in can
uh the fd sensor flexible data rate you
can get more data through um
faster
so this is what the cars are gonna be
shipping with
we wanna support it it's also just
changing one ship so this is pretty cool
we have one up here again
i'm sure another question on the red
panda um
since there's a panda in the c2 or the
c3 already
how does that work
do you bypass one do you switch one off
how does so you won't be able to use it
with the comma two um unfortunately
um this isn't like this is a hardware
limitation the combat two it's the same
reason you can't use a comma smaze on a
comma two okay um so i guess if you have
an eon you can use the red panda but um
any on gold
but
it'll use the usbc uh port on the comma
three oh the spare one okay okay yeah we
have one of our cars uh we have a red
panda one of our cars driving with the
com3 okay cool thank you
so one of the things you listed was uh
misra c2012 is that being applied to the
panda and also the um
open pilot no this is so openpilot is
considered qm uh in terms of our
functional safety analysis um panda is
where
that kind of code rigor happens um
and this is where we designate um the
safety being enforced okay and are you
applying anything like then cert at all
to the uh
for security another coding standard
uh considering you know making sure that
the code is written a certain way so
that there's no vulnerabilities or
anything like that
misroad does that in in some sense but
wondering if there was any other
standards that you're applying
uh these are you may as far as coding
standards or is code shell save coding
standards
so we uh
on the c code we also run we just run
some generic uh stack analysis tools
like cpp check so we use cpp check um
we use
some other static analysis stuff and
then they have a mizra add-on and then
we keep up to date with their mizr
add-on we even uh we fixed a couple bugs
in there
so we
pretty actively
work to work towards mizroc 2012 and for
functional safety standards are you then
applying like
uh iso 26262
process standards for
yeah so you can see uh it's pretty cool
if you go to panda you'll see we have
two projects we have an iso 262 project
and we have a sl2 project um from when
we did uh
in-depth functional safety analysis and
we made a bunch of uh issues and then
you can see the program you can see the
progress uh all the iso 262 stuff is
almost done all the cars that we
officially support have full i62 and
panda
and you self-certify uh
as well the code or the the for for
safety standards
like
yeah there's no certifying body there's
no okay
you said something about
declocking
uh one of the chips to reduce the heat
yeah in common too are all the
combinators that are out right now
um with the d clocked yep okay thanks
yup and running at about 55 60 overall
cpu so this is well below our target for
uh zero nine token zero nine
thanks for the presentation
so well the one question i have is uh
what will be the operating temperature
for the comma three will have the same
limitations that the comma two has
as far as maximum temperature that it
can be run at
so the active cooling in the common
three is is quite a bit better uh the
thermal thresholds may be a little bit
stricter because um
from what we see in our stress test
thermals are significantly better we see
about max temperature of 65
c you'll never see a combo 2 of 65c um
and this is the max for the comma 3.
um
it's
we might be a little bit more strict but
it's because we can we have more um we
have more room to be strict and
you'll see the active cooling is quite
good in the com3
hey how's it going i'm curious what
yield you guys tend to get on the
production units and when production
units fail quality control what tends to
be the the sort of common culprits
yeah so
like i said we
we do it in stages um so
we kind of establish processes we write
tests and then
production comes back after
some period of time a couple months or
so and
they're like okay here's what failed um
a lot we also do we have a lot of
logging around this that's why we're
able to make these uh cool histograms
and stuff comparing like all the
comments we shipped up until now and
then compared with the down clock
um so some of the common ones we saw
with the common too were like cpu too
hot
some of them don't have an imei so we're
able to filter filter out a lot of the
like the raw eco phones there was tons
of failures in those um that's like kind
of a cost we just have to eat
so we do a lot of filtering at every
level and there was
each kind of stage had its own uh
common failure stress test was cpu too
hot mostly
um
file provisioning
usually uh
catches things like oh this device
doesn't have a microphone stuff like
that
alright hadeeb
thank you so much
that was great
you